hier soir, les États-Unis ont traduit
en justice le chef terroriste numéro un au monde
Abu Bakar al-baghdadi
est mort il était le fondateur et le chef d'
Isis l'organisation terroriste la plus impitoyable et la plus violente
du
monde il a enflammé son gilet en se tuant
lui-même et les trois  enfants
son corps a été mutilé par l'explosion que le
tunnel avait cédé en plus
mais les résultats des tests ont donné
une identification certaine immédiate et totalement positive
c'était lui c'était un homme malade et dépravé
et maintenant il est parti Baghdadi était vicieux
et violent et il est mort en  une manière vicieuse et
violente en tant que lâche courant et
pleurant la nuit dernière a été une grande nuit pour
les États-Unis et pour le monde
un tueur brutal qui a causé tant de
difficultés et de mort a été violemment
éliminé il ne fera plus jamais de mal à
un autre homme innocent femme  ou enfant il est
mort comme un chien il est mort comme un lâche
le monde est maintenant un endroit beaucoup plus sûr
les forces d'opérations spéciales américaines ont exécuté une
nuit dangereuse et audacieuse  raid dans le
nord-ouest de la Syrie et accompli
leur mission et leur grand style aucun
personnel n'a été perdu dans l'opération
tandis qu'un grand nombre de
combattants et de compagnons de Baghdadi ont été tués avec
lui le niveau d'intelligence le niveau
de travail était assez incroyable lorsque nous avons
atterri avec huit hélicoptères un grand
une équipe de brillants combattants a couru hors de
ces
hélicoptères et a fait des trous dans le côté du
bâtiment ne voulant pas passer par la
porte principale parce que c'était piégé.
nous l'avons regardé si
clairement que je ne veux pas dire comment mais nous
avions absolument parfait comme si
vous regardiez un film ce raid était
impeccable et n'aurait pu avoir
lieu qu'avec la reconnaissance et l'aide
de certaines autres nations et personnes que je
tiens à remercier  les nations de la Russie, la
Turquie, la Syrie et l'Irak et je tiens également à
remercier les Kurdes syriens pour le
soutien certain qu'ils ont pu nous apporter,
c'était un  mission très très dangereuse